you're a scientist an
exo world-class scientist planetary
scientist
astronomer uh now i'm a bit of an idiot
who likes to ask silly questions so some
questions are a little bit in the realm
of speculation
almost philosophical because we know so
little
and one of the awesome things about your
work is you've actually put data and
real science behind some of the biggest
questions that we're all curious about
but nevertheless many of the questions
might be a little bit speculative
so on that topic uh just in your sense
do you think
we're alone in the universe human beings
do you think there's life out there well
lex the funny thing is is that as the
scientist
i so don't even want to answer that you
you really don't i will answer that yeah
but
i just loved you you resisted naturally
yeah we naturally resist that because we
want numbers
and hard facts and not speculation but i
do love that question it's a great
question
and it's one we all wonder about but i
have to give you the scientist answer
first
yeah sure which is we'll have the
capability to answer that question
soon even starting soon how do you
define soon
how do i define something so much
happened in the last hundred years
right right and there's a difference
right if it's 10 years or 20 years or
100 years yeah
there's a difference in that well soon
could be a decade
or two decades and then by the way
journalists usually don't like that or
the people want like tomorrow they want
the news but what it's going to take is
telescopes space telescopes or very
sophisticated ground or space telespace
telescopes to
let us study the atmospheres of other
planets far away and to look what's in
the atmospheres and to look for water
which is needed for life as we know it
to look for gases that don't belong that
we might attribute to life
so we have to do some really
nitty-gritty astronomy
so the the promising way to answer this
question
scientifically is to look for hints of
life that's where like many of your
ideas come in
of what kind of hints what might we
actually see about this life right right
that's exactly what we need to do and i
like the word you chose hint
because it's going to be a hint it's not
going to be 100 yay we found it
and then it will take future generations
to do more careful work to hopefully
even find a way to send a probe to these
distant exoplanets
and to really figure this out for us i
mean we'll talk about the details
those are fun but like uh back to the
speculation
zoomed out big pictures big picture is
yes
i believe absolutely there is life out
there somewhere
because there the vastness of the
universe is incredible
it's so breathtaking when we look at the
night sky if you can go to that dark sky
you can see you know many many hundred
or even
if you have good eyesight and you're
somewhere very dark you could see
thousands of stars
but in our galaxy we have hundreds of
billions of stars
and our universe has hundreds of
billions of galaxies
so think about all those stars out there
and even if planets are rare even if
life is rare
just because the number of stars is so
huge
things have to come together somewhere
someplace in our universe yeah it's so
amazing to think that somebody might be
looking up on another
planet in a distant galaxy
i have to interrupt your reverie and get
back to
in our lifetime at least the short term
we have to
we only have the nearest stars to look
at it's true that there are so many
stars
so many hosts for planets that might
have life but in the practical
question of will we find it it has to be
a star
quite close to earth like a few light
years tens of light years maybe hundreds
of light years
and by the way yeah you've introduced me
to a tool of uh
eyes on exoplanets i think uh
that nasa has put together isolated
exoplanets that's what's isn't it
software you guys it's so cool
but anyway can you give a sense of like
who our neighbors are like you said uh
hundreds of light years like how many
stars are close by
at like what what's our neighborhood
like we're talking about five
ten stars that we might actually have a
chance
to zoom in on i'm talking about maybe a
dozen or two dozen
stars and those are that's with planets
that look
suitable for us to follow up in detail
for life
right one thing that's really exciting
in this field is that
the very nearest start earth called
proxima centauri
is part of the alpha centauri star
system cool name by the way
proxima centauri appears to have a
planet around it
that's an earth map about an earth mass
planet in the so-called habitable zone
or the goldilocks zone of the host star
so think about how incredible that is
like out of
all the stars out there even the very
nearest star has planets and has a
planet of huge interest to us
you